[Music]
all right how we doing New
York so my name is Kevin this is our
first ever wind surf presentation so you
could say it's the first time we're kind
of spilling the beans on uh what the
idea is all about so thank you all for
coming I'm going to be talking about
wind surf the first AI agent powered
editor so my name is Kevin how I lead
our product engineering team we're a
team based out of uh San
Francisco and thank you so much to swix
and Ben and the whole AI engineering
Summit team for inviting us here and
letting us speak to you all um it's been
a pleasure talking to people in the
audience uh at the booth and just
generally talking about AI uh so let's
dive into it wind surf is an agentic
editor and we're going to talk a little
bit about some of the principles that we
use when we're building a product like
this so we believe that agents are the
future of software development and you
all are here so you kind of understand
the power of what agents can do both for
software engineering and otherwise um
but to start I'm going to take you down
a trip down memory lane right let's go
back to 2022 co-pilot was the
state-of-the-art it just came out of
beta people were experiencing the ghost
text they were seeing their completions
and it was one of the first first times
that people really got to see the magic
of what AI could do for developers was
making them more productive and we
codium um decided we were going to be
one of the first companies to also
launch an autocomplete product so we
garnered a couple million users on our
vs code jet brains Vim emac extensions
um raise your hand if you were one of
those codium users nice nice um but we
always knew that intelligence was going
to get better right back then we were
doing short completions maybe finishing
your functions but we knew that there
were going to be better models larger
models better training paradigms
completely new you know RL new tool use
all this stuff and so we knew that we
wanted to build the best experience for
devs possible so even back then we
started looking at agents we started
thinking about what could the future of
software development be if models just
got
bigger and so we built the best
experience that we could at the time and
that was a chat autocomplete product but
we always knew that copy pasting from
chat GPT was going to be a thing of the
past we also knew that people are going
to probably tab less we're going to have
llms that we'd be able to generate more
and more and who knows you know we
always think all right agents are the
best now but as a company we're always
thinking about the future we're
technology optimists so if an ID in the
future who knows we might not even be
writing code inside ID of inside of IDE
we'll just be there building the best
product for
S and so this year 2025 is finally the
year where I feel like we are all
recognizing the power of Agents inside
of software development agents are here
to stay and when wind surf I'm proud to
say is pushing the envelope of that
technology and we're going to talk about
some of those features um and we're
going to keep pushing that agentic
future um because we believe that you
know agents are going to move software
engineering in a direction that no other
llm has done in the
past so this slide I guess is titled
Vibe coding with wind surf or also just
coding in Wind surf um so I'm going to
give you a quick demo about this is the
wind surf product here you have a a bar
this is our
agent and you can see that we're going
to be building a python web scraper so
what this is going to do it's going to
build a python WebCrawler give us some
stats about the website um and you can
see it's actually installing
dependencies from pip um it's doing so
inside of the terminal that you use so
you can interact with it um it's
suggesting edits setting up your virtual
environment and we give a user a very
helpful accept and reject so that you
can go through and have confidence that
the code that it's generating works for
you and your codebase um this is of
course there's a lot more features under
the hood um some of the things that our
users like to do they like to look up
documentation we have web search enabled
by default um it always looks at your
codebase so you can grap through your
codebase uh we can generate commit
messages you can drag and drop images
right the possibilities are truly
endless and I'm going to be talking
about these features are powered by a
handful of principles a handful of
through lines that we as an engineering
team hold true as we're building and as
a team we always go back to the same
Mission which is to keep you in the
flow and unlock your Limitless potential
right we want to work on we want to
handle the grunt work for you we want to
handle looking at your debug stack
traces we want to handle modifying your
original source code we want to pull the
correct version of documentation so that
you never have to worry about pulling in
the correct context these are problems
that we are trying to solve um and we
want you to spend time on things that
you are good at right the things that
make us all excited which is shipping
products building great features um and
generally just shipping
code and so with that goal in mind how
do we tell what to work on um it's a
game of input and output so we want to
allow users to give the least amount of
explicit input possible to produce the
most correct and production ready code
right we want you to contribute less and
we want our agent to contribute more and
we do this by reducing the amount of
human in the loop required by doing
things like background research we are
always trying to predict your next step
and we'll make decisions on your behalf
so that you can move
faster and this might all seem like a
fantasy but winds surf launched three
months ago on November 13th um that date
is forever branded In My Memory um and
these are the results that we're already
seeing so in three months we've been
generating 4.5 billion lines of code it
is an absurd number and since the time I
started this presentation we've actually
probably sent users have probably sent
thousands of messages to Cascade asking
it to refactor code to write new
features to build new pages on their
website
um and also a fun statistic since we're
all Engineers here uh we've had 16
nights in the last you know 90 days
where we've been woken up in the middle
of the night from pager Duty on call
because we've had some reliability
issues um due to us exceeding our
capacity right these problems these
we've had immense success getting people
onto the platform um and we've been very
fortunate to have the issue of being
some of anthropic and open ai's largest
uh
consumers and so with these Mission with
this Mission and Metric in mind let's
walk through some of the principles that
we use when we're building this agentic
editor and for those of you that have
used wind surf um you might learn about
some of the new ways that you could use
the product and also for my own
curiosity how many of you have heard of
wind surf just so I know who we're
talking about oh let's
go that's sick um how many of you use
wind surf okay everyone who put their
hand down do over there um all right
let's get into it so the first principle
trajectories what is a trajectory we use
trajectories to read your mind so unlike
edit other editors like cursor the
elephant in the room our agent is deeply
integrated into the editor and we'll
talk about what exactly that means but
on one half you can imagine an agent has
to understand what you're doing and then
on the other half it has to understand
and be able to execute things on your
behalf and this has led to features like
one of my favorites quote continue my
work so we are building up an
understanding of the user as you're
writing code as you're executing
terminal commands and then you can
actually just go into the the agent
sidebar and just say continue my work
and it'll actually continue executing
that and it might even give you a full
PR or a full commit right we also have
things like terminal execution mode
right it can automatically use the llm
to decide what is safe and not safe so
that if you're running something like
git it'll just work or if you it'll
probably prompt you if there's an rmrf
somewhere you probably don't want to run
that automatically and the llm would be
like oh we should probably flag to the
user to confirm this these are just some
of the ways that we try and let the
human be in the loop but as minimal as
possible and then finally we also have
you know a a stellar ux a stellar design
team that's been working on how to
integrate these sort of Cutting Edge
features into a product in a way that
allows the user to feel like they're in
control to be able to accept and reject
changes into their code so they can have
confidence in the code that they're
pushing to
production so here is how a trajectory
Works um we have this notion of a
unified timeline so an agent is working
in the background behind the scenes to
understand what the user is implicitly
doing so this includes things like
viewing files navigating around your
codebase um let's say you edit a file uh
and then the agent will edit a file this
all kind of goes into a shared timeline
of actions you can imagine this includes
things like searching grepping um making
edits making commits right the user has
this sort of holistic understanding of
what you're
doing and this entire experience is
Unified by this shared timeline so you
can contribute to it it can contribute
to it and in this way you never run into
the problem where you're talking to the
agent and it undo the change that you
just did or has some you know outdated
notion of what the file state is so this
is a first class principle of ours and
when we decided we were going to build
an editor we were going to build it
around this notion of an agent in a
shared
timeline and so here's an example of
this feature in action here we're adding
a new function and you're seeing the
autocomplete and all the kind of like
bells and whistles of that feature and
in the right side we just asked continue
my work this is a new function we
probably want our form Handler to use
this new function and you can see based
on the context that we gave it by making
edits it's guessing Okay we probably
want to make this file change to this
file maybe some others and then at the
end it's actually just saying okay let's
just run npm run Dev and it can run
terminal commands on your behalf in the
background in your kind of like command
J terminal popup um and in this way
we're keeping you in the flow right
something that would have taken minutes
is now taking
seconds and here's another example uh
the terminal is now deeply integrated
into the agentic timeline so here if
you're typing commands you know the
classic example is like I npm install a
new package or I pip install a new
package the agent should know oh you
just installed this package why don't we
go ahead and implement it into your
project and based on context that it's
able to pick up around the codebase it
can continue that line of work so we
very strongly believe in a future of no
copy paste right you should never have a
situation where you're in a terminal or
you're in a document or even on a
website and you're copy pasting text
into an agent that's that's just not how
the way the world works and in the same
way we strongly believe the future is
not going to be at
Terminal here's another example of
commands running inside of your terminal
I've been talking about this for a
little bit and this concept of a
trajectory allows us to automatically
execute things inside of a Sandbox that
is as similar to the way you run
commands as possible so instead of
running some shell script in the
background what we do is we put this
right inside of the place that you would
actually write terminal commands so if
you pip install something or it pip
install something it's going to the same
environment you'll never have this
instance of kind of weirdness and and
this is all part of our effort to bring
these two sides the agentic side and The
Human Side close together as close
together as possible and you do this
through building a unified
product we believe that developers are
here to stay and if you want to work
seamlessly with a developer that means
the agent has to understand what they
are thinking wind surf has to be
ubiquitous and the agent will be reading
more and more of your mind doing things
that you might not even know it's doing
in the future we'll be looking not just
one to five steps in the future but 10
20 30 steps into the future it'll be
writing unit tests before you've even
finished defining the function it'll be
performing codebase wide refactors on
multiple files based on you just simply
editing a variable name all this is part
of this unified trajectory
concept now the second principle is meta
learning so even if wind surf
understands what you're doing in the
moment there is still an inferred
understanding of your codebase and your
preferences and your organizational
guidelines that let's just say senior
engineers at your company have built up
a notion of over time we call this
concept meta learning so wind surf we've
built from the ground up to to adapt and
remember these things about you and your
company so if you think about a frontier
llm right the best llms that they exist
in the world they're very very smart
Engineers definitely more capable than
than I probably more capable than most
of you they can just write an enormous
amount of code and do so correctly and
it probably runs and compiles pretty
well but what they do not have is the
exposure that you've had the education
that you've had and the ability to kind
of remember and and know how you
personally or your company writes code
and so what does this mean for our
product we've implemented a concept
called autogenerated Memories so over
time we build up a memory bank what you
are doing so you can say remember that I
use tailn version 4 or remember that I
use react 19 instead of 18 and these
things will be remembered you say them
once in the be remembered forever we
also allow people to implement things
like custom mCP servers so you can plug
in your favorite tools we can adapt to
your workflow we will also allow you to
wh list and Blacklist commands going
back to that same concept we want to
keep you in the flow as least or sorry
we want to keep you in the flow as much
as possible but we can tell the agent
hey never run an RM command without my
approval and so in this way it learns
about your preferences over
time and if you think about what makes a
developer effective it's because they
remember things that you tell them and
Wier must also model this Behavior if we
hope that AI should write and maintain
projects for us so in the short term
this means you don't need to prompt the
agent again and again to do the same
thing over and over um but in the long
term the AI should just feel like a
seamless extension of yourself it's this
idea of explicit versus inferred
context and we always have the saying at
the company ideas are cheap so here's an
example of autogenerated memories in
action here we're not even explicitly
telling it remember this thing we're
just giving it an architecture overview
we're asking what does this project do
and it's remembering based on a couple
tool uses it's looking at a couple
different files looking at the routes
and now it's committed to memory hey
this is the project that this person is
working on here are the endpoints that
are available and we can reference that
in the next message that we send right
so in the next future conversation we
can now One-Shot things because we have
a notion of a memory bank in the same
way documentation is auto learned we
know what packages you're using because
of your package Json because you've
exped L told us and we're able to look
up the web look on the web for
documentation that matches those
versions and we do so all
implicitly and so the dream of meta
learning is that you can have an
entirely inferred sense of context based
on a code base or based on the usage of
the product and autogenerated memories
are a step in that direction um we
strongly believe that having a rules
file you know we do allow users to to
add a rules file we strongly believe
that a rules file is a crutch you know
by the end of 2025 99% of the things
that you're going to put in a rules file
will be interpreted or inferred based on
your code base or your usage so our
dream is that every single wind surf
instance every single user using wind
surf regardless of the company or the
type of person the skill of the
developer will be personalized to that
user and you'll only have to tell it one
thing and finally my favorite principle
which is scale with intelligence so what
does this mean now that wind surf
understands what you're doing in the
moment right the first principle and can
improve over time the second principle
how do we actually build an agent that
will scale with the rates at which llms
are scaling and while we're trying to
get always give you the best tool today
we recognize that new models are coming
out every other week right every day
there's some new article about some new
pattern and it's really really hard to
keep up but we always think at codium
how do we stay on top of this how do we
build the best product for not just
today but three months six months 12
months out three years from now so in
2021 when chat GPT came out you probably
like me we all had our imaginations
running wild we're like okay we're going
to solve you know AGI post economy
whatever but obviously there's a lot of
things that need to happen between then
and that future and so models at that
time were quite frankly a little bit too
too dumb to be able to comp accomplish
everything that we wanted them to do so
we built up a lot of infrastructure and
you and I have all probably done this we
build out embedding indices we build
retrieval heris we have output
validating systems to make sure that the
code that it's generating is good right
these are all things that were able to
help at the margin but this is all
predicated on the assumption that we
were operating with a fixed notion of
intelligence 2021 2022 these models we
were operating we were building all this
infrastructure to compensate for areas
and edge cases that models could not
handle and what's very different about
the way we're approaching wind surf is
that we want our product to scale with
the models so if the models get better
our product gets better and I'll give
you one such example um it kind of
surprised me I was you know when I
landed in New York I tweeted that we
deleted chat in Cascade I was like a
very I don't know I was just I had
thoughts and weirdly a lot of you picked
this up and this is an example of
something that we feel very strongly
about one example of this principle in
practice is that we deleted chat so what
does this mean we only have an agent and
it's called Cascade inside of winds surf
chat is a legacy Paradigm and we
completely replaced it and as you can
see here users are enjoying it or in
fact they might not even know the but
they're just enjoying the higher
quality an example of this is at
mentions we built at mentions and
probably you all have used mentions
because context was not very good a year
two years ago today wind surf can
dynamically infer the relationships
between bits of code and documents 90%
of the time you do not need to at
mention something all you need to do is
let the retrieval system in the agent
kind of plan out what it needs to do and
then reconstruct the context
automatically for you so at file and at
web these are very helpful patterns when
you're working at kind of the margin but
these are eventually eing out basis
points in the long term we believe that
llms are going to improve and they
already have improved to the point where
you don't need to explicitly specify an
at mention the llm should be intelligent
enough to pick it up and so in this
example previously I was implementing
superbase inside of a xjs app previously
you'd be at webbing you'd be at docs at
codebase at this at that no just add
superbase right and it's able to infer
and plan out let's search the web let's
behave like a human would and to get
into this there's there's also web
search built into um winds Surf and
what's very special about this is that
it reads the web the way a human would
read the web so instead of these
hardcoded rules and you know we probably
could have created an edding index but
we would probably get very low quality
results and so instead we said the llms
are very very good let's let the model
decide what it wants to do let's have it
decide which search results to read what
parts of the page to read and then
finally give us an answer
and so we believe that as models will
continue to get better we're going to be
continuing to do unsupervised work we're
going to generate full PRS we're going
to read complex documentation the
possibilities are truly
endless and so here are some of the
principles that we just talked
about um where are we going with this
there's a lot of ways we can take this
right the engine underneath wind surf is
really really the secret sauce and we
believe that we're going to be 2025 is
going to be a whole new world no rules
files generating PRS generating commits
it's going to be be crazy and we're
already seeing this 90% of our users or
sorry all of our users 90% of the code
that they're writing is generated with
Cascade that's an astonishing number
autocomplete was more in like the 20 30%
this is insane right people are using
agents today to accomplish so much more
than they could have in the past and
we're all software Engineers I want to
make sure that every single person in
this room is armed with the best tools
and those best tools are
agents and like every good thing in the
city
I expect tips 25% of your ticket price
which I heard was quite a lot um here's
the actual QR that you're probably
curious about um this is when surf's
download link we offer a free tier um so
go ahead and and scan that start using
the magic
today and then finally we have some
killer swag at our booth um you can also
connect with me on Twitter I try and
stay active with the community but thank
you so much for watching I hope that you
all learned something about how we're
building at Surf and enjoy the rest of
the conference
[Music]